Thank you everyone for this special
edition of talks at Google as a fireside
chat with Mr Nadine, who, uh,
Mr Nadine Loseanne is one of Asia's
leading social impact entrepreneurs,
tech investors and financial
inclusion pioneers.
He is the founder of telling
all microfinance bank,
formerly the meal microfinance recognized
by the World Bank as one of the
largest and most socially impactful
bags. And, uh, the field globally,
uh,
easy besa offering from the bank past
revolutionized Pakistan's mobile financial
services industry. His latest
Venture Planet End Group is Pakistan,
is foremost technology growth
capital and incubator platform,
uh,
focusing on financial
inclusion and facilitation of
entrepreneurship in Pakistan
through technology. And he
has added 24 companies, uh,
do his portfolio across ecommerce,
financial technology,
educational technology, mobile
television, retail and renewable energy.
Let's welcome our speak speaker.
Uh,
you had,
uh, you had an unusual, the beginning, uh,
often spending nearly 30 years in banking.
You came back to Pakistan,
just start a new venture at the age of 49.
Um,
what was easy and what was hard to
start something new at that age.
And how did you decide to
start a microfinance back
back in Boston after having
lived in different countries?
So I spent about 27 years,
but Citi group in about
eight different countries.
And my last assignment was actually out
of the Bible that was disposable for
Iraq during the sovereign debt
restructuring. So of that 27 years,
I'd spent half my time in investment,
consumer banking and half
my diamond disc management.
I was 49 years old and I'd figured
out that pretty seven years,
I'd only spent five years in Pakistan
launching the consumer banking Pakistan.
Otherwise I'd been outside Pakistan and
I felt it was time for me to go back and
do something in Pakistan.
Pakistan had been kind to me.
I got where I had because of my,
you know,
education in Pakistan and subsequently
in the u s but I want this tag of saying
that I've done enough of city,
you know,
I had become relatively senior
in Citi bank making decent money,
but I wanted to go back and create
something in Pakistan, which would be,
I hoped I would be able
to change an industry.
It was very ambitious for a person who
had only worked five years in Pakistan
and had actually never
done microfinance before.
And reason I wanted to do microfinance
were two fold. One was simply capital.
If I want to do own a bank in Pakistan,
a commercial bank capital requirement,
it was $100 million and a microfinance
capital requirement was 10 million donors.
As you can see,
that decision was an easy decision to
get into as far as capital department.
It was a good son,
but this huge financial exclusion in
Pakistan of our country right now have 200
million people.
Less than 6.7 million people
have access to formal credit.
So my view was that if we could
create a microfinance bank,
which could actually structural as this
process, do, you know, create a bag,
which was done by professionals
as opposed to necessarily.
But it's not that the other
institution I'd run by professional,
but people who had cabinet,
Margaret Experience,
people who are consumer experience,
people who are global experience.
You would have to learn microfinance
because all my knowledge of microfinance
was a book written by Doctor Eunice.
So I hadn't done microfinance before,
so that was a challenge.
But I taught it we will be able to create
a world class institution using the 27
years of knowledge I had at city and the
capital had buildup at city, you know,
two options.
And was it the funny part is
that when I exited Citibank,
Citibank stark was $35 you know,
it came down to close to $2 afterwards.
So there wasn't, you know, my
bar, it was, you know, uh, luck.
But right now I was reading the Citi
Bank stock is cynical of stock is back to
2009 years.
It was at night.
It was a big decision in the sense
that I'd spent 27 years working for one
company, getting a salary in a very
comfortable environment. You know,
when you're getting a check every month,
you're getting a nice bonus.
Every year you get transported to a new
country and the company takes care of
you. It's a nice life and it's not boring
because you're moving from country to
country. So the new market, so
you're always getting, you know,
a different experience. When
I was growing up, you know,
like most Pakistani's at that stage,
my ambition was to become a
head of a multinational in
Pakistan because you know,
it's a great job. You get a lot of perks,
make 1 million bucks and I'd be done.
You know, that was my initial ambition.
Uh, you know, I'd be happy camp.
I never had that stage taught at work
for myself or create a company for myself
because that whole mindset that
I was to go find a multinational,
do work for,
you know,
and get promoted and become a country
head or maybe a regional head.
So the first transition was that I
would be creating my own company and my
family comes from a
middle class in Pakistan.
My father used to be in the Pakistan
Navy and then garden and the automotive
industry.
My mother was a high school principal.
There was no examples of any
entrepreneurship in my family.
So I was the first person to
actually move from a salary job into,
you know,
an entrepreneurship kind of thing.
So that was the first
decision moving away,
the safety net of a nice
tax free job in Dubai,
coming back to Pakistan and you know,
putting my own capital at risk.
So out of the 10 million, you
know, I put in $6 million IFC,
we know $1 million,
and they would do local investors that
put in 3 million to get to the 10 million.
The second thing was I had never
worked in Pakistan beyond five years.
And actually I was a Pakistani,
used to go back every year to Pakistan
working in Pakistan, you know,
especially in the microfinance
environment would be very different.
So that was another challenge, uh, that,
uh, you know, I knew I would experience,
but I'm impulsive kind of person.
So once the bug bit me that
I was going to walk back,
I actually didn't even paid for my bonus
that dia incidentally would've been
half a million bucks because we had
just finished the sovereign debt,
destruction of Pakistan and the city bag
and made close to $120 million on that
deal. It was a massive deed.
Uh, so I was country had Iraq,
but I, I couldn't wait so I
just given my resignation.
So going to go back to Pakistan and
you know, my boss said, you know,
you're going to be going on for
abiding by, it was four months away.
I didn't know. I can't
wait. I've got to go back.
And I just went back and
started talking about bank.
Well my current to prices tend
to estimate the demand side.
Interest rates are typically higher
for microloans and recent randomized
controlled trials show that direct
cash transfers that is cash without any
strings attached, has more impact
on poverty and livelihoods.
So how does tend in all bag,
uh,
ensure that micro loans side impactful
in upward mobility and breaking out of
the poverty cycle for the communities.
I thought this is,
we want to be easy interview.
So there are two schools of thought and
both come up with scientific evidence.
One says in the controlled
group environment,
when you do microfinance lending,
it would a period of time we
actually show improvement.
And there's not an equal group of people
who actually demonstrate that. No,
you cannot isolate that improvement.
Whether it's uh, you know,
floor that had been
converted from you know,
mud to wood or a bathroom within put in
or kids are going to school or there's
less people getting sick because of the
incremental income that you have is not
necessarily due to the intervention
of the microfinance bank,
but they could be other sources
of income coming in and you put,
because money's fungible,
you can't necessarily isolate the impact.
Microfinance lending is ag.
So both exist and you know,
both I've done by very prominent people
who've done ab testing and demonstrated
that deer right in my 11 years,
my sense was that I met enough customers
that we changed the lives that we know
then dimension we had done had made
them actually better off than they were
before.
The big risk in microfinance is that
over in depthness you get a customer,
do we actually take more money than he
or she can rebate and that's when the
default, otherwise it typically the
rates of default and microfinance,
if you got the right underwriting,
I typically in the 1% the big challenge
in microfinance is not that your
customer is going to default
because they don't have,
they haven't given you collateral.
It's your business model.
How do you take care of
the long tail customer?
Your Business Model takes into account
that you're going to sell as opposed to a
bag of tea bags,
one sachet at the time.
So you have to build a business model
that incorporates it just selling one
sachet at a time.
And unless you can do that,
and that's why large commercial banks are
not successful in microfinance because
their business model is
very different as you know,
mandarin million dollars or $10
million or $200,000 of loan at a time.
But microfinance is one loan acquired at
a time for an average of maybe $350 or
$300 where the customer has
no finances, no, you know,
credit report of any kind.
And you're actually estimating the
ability to repay the debt service by human
intervention.
And that's the reason the typically
microfinance rates a high,
it's not because microfinance
banks make a lot of money.
So if you look at globally,
what kind of, you know,
money microfinance banks make or
microfinance institutions make,
it's not a very high number.
You will send them,
you'll find a microphone has magnetic
bank making $100 million of $50 million
income. It's rare, I would say,
you know, a good current, you know,
but 10 banks globally would do that.
The reason the rates are highest is the
cost of customer acquisition and the
cost of underwriting.
So if you look at an industry that's it,
industry is 30% and you
said, well, you know,
you're going to be poor guy and you're
learning at 30% and that's not fair.
I mean, you're gouging. The
customer is already very poor.
So what service are you providing?
You've just maximizing your own returns.
But if you break and
peel that onion of 30%,
you find out that out of that 30%,
typically 15% is customer administration.
Why?
Because there's no,
I mean,
very few microfinance banks
use scorecards for the Bowman.
So everything is human intervention.
Tommy Bank at 2000 people by the time I
was exiting because you need to go and
see the customer,
you need to figure it out at the
able to repay your debt or not.
So you have to go a couple of times to
figure out what their repayment ability
is.
Because typically in developing country
that that level corruption is high
because these people are
not used to getting anything
done without paying money.
So if they need a passport, they need,
uh, you know, uh, a CAC card, which is,
you know,
like identity because they're always
being some kind of money to touching
between.
So typically the imagery
immediately offering money
to your relationship manager
and that's something you,
you know,
you want to avoid because you want to
have a culture where money's being taken.
So you have a separate person.
We ain't gonna benefit ration process
when they go and recheck that the
customer's estimation of what you're
estimating the EPM and is correct.
When you have to talk to the neighbor
to see if this person living in is,
you know,
how has been a long time or what type of,
then you go to his place of work
and talk to his neighbor again.
So it's a very laborious people
intensive process. It commercial banks,
customer administration is typically
around 2% 3% it microfinance banks is 15%
then you have pasta funds that typically
commercial banks have low cost to fire
because they have checking accounts
or they have savings accounts.
Typically microfinance banks
don't have checking card.
They can tell me the bank had one,
uh,
but most magnifier and banks and dependent
on going to the interbank market to
raise money because the customer's
view is if I have to borrow money,
I borrowed from microfinance bag,
but if I have to deposit money,
I'll go to a commercial bank because
your money's safe. So if I'm to,
that's the kind of fat,
if you're willing to lend to me,
you can't be all that
you know, uh, you know,
strong and by your capital.
Adequacy is concerned.
So it takes time for
microfinance banks to,
you use the cost of funds to typically
you borrowing 300 basis points over the
money market rate. So let's save the money
market brain Pakistan was 6% typical.
My girlfriend has borrowed,
we'll borrow it,
nine to 10% so 15% plus 10% like 25%
let's say the Ford is 1% so you're 26% if
your margin of one or 2% at
28 so the rates are high,
but that's the decent
rates. If microfinance bag
start embracing technology,
you can bring the
administration countdown.
If every time you'd approving secondary
using score cards or artificial
intelligence to create algorithms,
we can forecast,
you know what your default
rate is going to be.
You can bring some of the administration
cost dunk. If you create, you know,
checking account or
mobile account program,
you can bring your cost of funding down.
So my timing,
my ambition was to bring art.
[inaudible] was 28% trimming it down to
15% and credit card rates in Pakistan at
30 32% so, you know, hopefully the new
management is looking towards that.
But that's the reason,
you know,
microfinance is rates range from 30% to
40% but they don't make that much money.
It's because of the way this
whole business model is.
So tell it all that has created and
instituted a successful mobile payment
system called easy besser and many have
tried to introduce mobile money in Asia,
but they've been right through successes.
How did go about creating
a new infrastructure and
network to enable the mobile
money? What are the challenges you
faced and how did you overcome that?
So,
so the biggest challenge in creating a
mobile distribution network is behavior
change or you got to realize that the
poor are willing to pay for services.
They don't want charity.
And their view of value for money is much,
much more acute than yours and mine.
So, you know, we spent some extra money,
but they have a finite budget and they
have to work within that and they're
willing to pay for value.
If you create value,
they now we're never
going to be pay for one,
but this is a behavior change requirement.
So when we looked at Pakistan,
you know, and, and we said, listen,
this financial exclusion that we
have is not limited to credit.
It's also limited to savings.
Since 1947 or Pakistan was created,
it's could be 70 years.
You know,
this month the entire commercial
banking industry's only open close to 32
million bank accounts.
And if I take unique bank account,
you're probably talking about 15 million
and the savings to GDP ration Pakistan
is under 6% so we said there ought to
be a solution for savings as well and
savings can generation get
generated when you start payments.
So how do we create a payment
culture, parks, a cash society,
and there's about three point 3 trillion
repeats of money floating in the system
because everybody plays catch in
a country of 200 million people.
Unfortunately registered
taxpayers are about 1.2 million.
The bulk of the taxes are collected
or indirect places. So you know,
people don't have bank accounts,
they want to keep money but
they use money all the time.
Cash and cash is
expensive. Uh, you know a,
there I depreciate in terms, you know
its physical form you need to carry,
it can get stolen. So if
you can do digital payments
many ways you're better off.
So we said, okay, we want to get
into the brightness banking business.
And again,
the idea of easy Pesa didn't just come
to me and I went to Kenya to look at m
Pesa.
I went to Philippines,
need to look at g cash and I looked
at various applications and said and
obviously telling,
nor was a partner at that time.
So they had some insights as well.
And we said the easiest way to get
people to start using Brandis banking is
payment of utility bills.
Now you guys talk typically
pay through your phone maybe,
but in Pakistan every month,
other than the telco payments,
30 million utility bills
are created core power, gas,
water,
and people typically go to
a bank getting online in a,
during banking hours, give up the
work time to make that payment.
And bags hate these people
because they can just the lobby.
So can again imagine they're not bank
customer that is coming to page to dibels
and the standing and the teller.
Why the bank customers on the side.
So the main mega as difficult as
possible for these guys to play. Uh,
but that was the only venue and we said,
okay,
if we can create a mechanism where we
just start accepting utility bills and
make it easier compared to
what they're doing right now.
When you started behavior change,
12,700 banks in Pakistan,
9,080 ms where people never use ADM for
repayment bills or do you can 95% of you
was just for cash withdrawals.
Does the typical, you know, psyche,
you can even make a interbank payment
through ATM when people don't,
they just use it for cash withdrawn.
That's likely go globally.
So we said Pakistan has now
let's say 90 million unique sims.
You know,
people would fall under 120 million,
same cards outstanding and
99% of those are prepared.
So it's not like postpaid account.
So here the most people actually buy
scratch cards or do a top up very
frequently, you know, in the month
whenever they run out of same balance.
In order to accommodate that,
the telcos had to set up a vast Asian
network where people could go and buy Sim
cards. It's like India, like Bangladesh
and most developing countries.
So the Telcos had set up agent network
multiple of what the bank branch network
was.
So the Vision Board,
if you can create the change that 80
network into providing basic banking
service, like opening an account,
closing an account, making utility bill,
making a transfer, then you would
actually create an alternative network,
which would be far more convenient for
the target market we were looking at,
because this network
is in the neighborhood,
it's open seven days a week is
open probably 14 hours a day.
The one that doesn't go to play golf,
you know,
so it's something that's service oriented
because these agents are selling a
whole bunch of other stuff
other than just a time.
So we basically started onboarding
telco agents for accepting utility bill
payments. Now that was the behavior
change. When these customers go to a bank,
they see a bank brand disease,
you know the board of the bank and
they're comfortable that my payment when I
make it,
it's going to go through the drilling
company and my power won't be cut off.
So we're telling them,
hey guys would you know,
go to the small shop the moment Bob
Store in your neighborhood and pay your
utility bill and you're going to be okay.
And the guy says, hell no. You know,
if I can make this payment and this guy
shanks on tomorrow and my power gets cut
off, who am I? Where's
my dress? Who do I go to?
So we tried to overcome that by
issuing a receipt by telling our bank.
So we said, listen, General Bank,
simply bank regulated entity.
If you power get cut off, you can take
the bank part of the central bank,
the central bank will make you whole.
And the second policy we had what?
Because the average payment was very
small and the aboriginal average payment
for the common man was under 2000 rupees.
So our policy was never dispute.
Just make that payment.
So the power that never gets cut off,
even if you think the customer in
the wrong, just make that payment,
get that confidence level up.
So there's behavioral change takes place.
Two people start paying the utility
bills at the local mom and pop store as
opposed to a bank. And that was, you know,
the change we want to do it.
And a lot of campaigns,
we tried to literally beg
brand ambassadors standing
at this moment pop stores.
So you know, Trinity Bill,
it's interesting is here's
the receipt and you know,
I want policy was no dispute,
just pay. And you know,
the time I left,
uh,
Tommy Bank was doing 10% of the
30 million bill pays three myths,
3 million base would be bills were being
paid through us. And that customer,
Sally's for confidence of actually new
going to a woman pop store and bring a
banking transaction started.
So that was the initial step.
The second step we said, you know,
it was an annual, you when you,
if you're a startup, you make great
plans and many go to the ground.
You sometimes find out that
those plans are, you know,
are in the base of a basket
because you call it drunk,
but you have to figure out a way to pivot.
So we thought our biggest product was
going to be international remittance.
Pakistan gets $17 billion a year
from workers in the Middle East,
in the UK and in the u s and we said,
you know,
bank branches, 12,700 closed on
a Sunday, half day on Saturday,
close long period on Friday for prayers.
We would be able to use
our agents across Pakistan,
60,000 agents and be able
to do this payment out.
And then therefore the large payment
provider that flood to come to us because
we would have said great distribution.
Well the only thing we miscalculated was
the average limiters size is $40,000.
Sorry,
40,000 rupees.
And the small agent doesn't have liquidity
to pay out five of these moments in a
day.
And all you need is if you,
if a Pakistan is go to ATM is not
working it's yard, no problem.
But if you go to withdraw cash from a
brother's Magni agent and there's no cash,
they said, oh, this guy's a fraud.
And the toll conference level,
you've built up changes. So our
international image, this product failed.
But in the whole learning process,
we are necessarily that there's a
huge component of domestic limiters,
$15 billion that paid domestically
in Pakistan and has gone through.
The way the money's transferred is
through some nickel hawala Hornby,
which is informal
payments through you know,
money agents or to the
post office or you know,
people were into your home down and
you just give them the guys too.
They give it to, you know,
your family back home.
And we said let's try domestic limiters
and domestic limiters with a phenomenal
success. And as I said,
in our regional plan,
there was no domestic limiters
as a product. But that's when we,
you start pivoting to when you were
original plan fails week and that's what
actually achieved the biggest behavior
change and the industry we created that
instead of going to informal channels,
you would go to an easy pesa agent
and say, I want to transfer money.
And he will say,
who do you want to transfer to?
And in Pakistan there's a universal
identifier called a computerized national
identity card. So it's a 16 digit
number. Everybody has, you know,
you just got can't live without anyone.
We didn't do anything,
so I would promise jobs
transferring money to you.
I would show them my CAC card. I would
give them yours, NFC card number.
If you're in a cell phone,
I'll give you a cell phone number.
I'd give my cell phone number and then
the agent would hand over his feature
phone. Because remember you're
working on SMS at that time,
smart phones hadn't come in and he
would ask you to put in a pin number six
digit. Now incidentally, in
90% of the spinning numbers
were one, two, three, four,
five, six but ideally,
how we all came back
and within three minutes that money
was available at 60,000 agents and the
beneficiary would go to the agent and say,
I have the money come.
And he would say, okay, show me your CIC.
And they will physical should
have crs and say, okay.
They would give him the phone and say,
put in your pin.
But obviously if one two three four
five six for bill and the money would be
drawn to,
it was a huge change from wedding,
from the post office or informal services
and it was phenomenally successful.
So we got to the second stage,
you know,
of what was getting people not get to
a comfort level after utility bills,
just start making domestic remittances.
Uh,
the problem was that we went to the agent,
the agent said,
I'm not going to do this.
You know,
I make a hundred percent margin on the
things I sell. This thing takes time.
You want me to add, you know, at
least 40 characters. But Damn,
I'm done with the trust zone.
We're going to add the CDIC number
from myself since I see number for you.
Just extend, there's 32 digits. I'm
going to add a 16 digit pin, 38 digits.
It's gonna take time.
So they extracted the pound of flesh.
Then for every dollar we made,
they took 70 cents.
That's the price we paid for getting the
agent that worked to absorb or accept
that as banging with miss 30 cents.
We're left with the split between
the Telcor Tylenol and Tommy Bank.
So we had to then look at doing huge
volumes to be able to make money.
But the agents were very happy because
initially they were reluctant but then
the style signing up.
But,
but the end state was mobile wallet
because we are still learning to Bradley's
bagging because we've got physical
interaction. You have to go to an agent.
It's like when I talked to him,
you know I see an ad in the paper which
says Xyz Bank has opened a digital
branch. You can walk into the branch
and there's no human intervention.
And I said to myself,
why in the hell would I want to get in
my car who travel for five minute miles
and then go to the branch and say,
wow, digital branch, you know,
this is the smart phone
is my digital branch.
I should be able to transact everything.
Boys sitting in my bed bed watching
season three of game of Thrones.
And you know, the latest episode
and do my transactions. So you know,
it's just mind boggling for me
in or this digital brand content,
no human in dementia. Maybe it's you
know, busy street next to your office.
But why would I even want to walk
any way to do my transactions?
So our next dog,
it was creating mobile wallets that if
we could create mobile wallets instead of
just physical activity and if the
customer was able to populate the mobile
wallet, then you know, person to person
transactions, utility bill payments,
person to business transactions,
gtpb government,
the person projections would take place.
And the three point 3 trillion
repeats floating in the system.
We start coming into the magnet system
and we would have a secondary revenue
stream, but we would have some
float on these mobile wallets.
Was it the transaction fee?
So initially we had a hurdle or how to
open these bank accounts because the
central bank required a physical face to
face to open a bank account for Kyc and
anti money laundering.
Barbara says that to know your customer,
you've got to see them.
Now that's a difficult call.
That means I either the customer would
have to go to my branch and my brand and
my network of agents would not be able
to open or they would have to take a
photograph of the customer photograph
of the CIC with men, the deck,
the feature phone wouldn't work because
of pixel quality was too poor and the
agent would have to have a smartphone
and who would fund that smartphone?
So our advantage of having a
large network Carney got me know,
uh, under leveraged as a consequence
of this requirement. But at zero,
sometimes things happen in the industry,
which don't happen because of view,
but you get to benefit from.
So the Ministry of Interior decided that
every person with a cell phone had to
be biometrically verified because there
were a lot of activities taking place.
Sometime kidnapping, some time,
terrorist activity from cell force,
they could learn defy.
So if I give myself my
identity card at the time,
I'm making a transaction
to us, you know, uh,
Bradley's bagging the agent that brings
bang agent would take my Sinesi card and
have five Muslims issue,
which I didn't know about it.
So the Pakistan Telecom Authority first
came up with a way that if you put in
your senior as the card number,
you find out how many scenes
have been issued in your names.
And I didn't mind at 15 sims and I knew
that only three of those were mine and
the rest.
But you know,
people using my energy for creating
a Sim card, you know, account,
uh, were Delco. They were paying
them on time, but above my same,
and if tomorrow something happened,
you know,
the agencies or I would be
responsible. So first, you know,
this whole tage took place
of political Simms went away,
but they still said is not working.
So they said every sim has to
be biometrically verified too.
So if you hold the phone,
you would have to go into an agent
and be biomedically verified,
which would be verified by the
national entity. Based we have,
which is called Nada.
And then your son would become active.
And if you wanted a same
immediately you couldn't get one.
You'd have to get biometric,
you'd have to do the official address
and it'll be delivered to your home.
That took away like 35 million seems from
the telephone market in me, you know,
the period of time in the Sim to place.
But then we had a very strong case and we
went to the central bank and said, Hey,
this sim is biometrically
verified by the central database.
Why am I required to see a customer?
Let's create bank accounts in line with
transactions and know your customer
risk. So let's say we have
some nick on 11 zero account.
This level zero gown says
you can do 50,000 rupees.
Every thousand rupees is $50
of transactions in a month.
That's good for 90% of Pakistanis.
Given the per capita income we have send
me back the loudest and the industry to
do a remote account opening.
So all you ever do is to send
an SMS to four of the banks,
which are connected with telcos. And you
can open a wealth account. The store,
the first thing that came about
was the one minute account,
which actually doesn't exist in
many countries, including here.
You have to physically go into a
bank to open an account. In Pakistan,
you can open a level zero count
remotely under one minute.
So this hurdle of opening a mobile
account went away with dispute regulation.
And right now there are 27 million
mobile accounts in Pakistan over a three
period as opposed to the
2030 2 million bank accounts.
There's 1947 so branchless banking or
technology can actually make huge impact,
you know, when used properly and
it can change behavior of people.
So obviously nothing is easy.
So we have 27 million,
23 million mobile accounts.
But the next question you would ask me is,
that's great.
How many are active?
Because opening an account is easy
because I ran a sales campaign where the
agent gets paid for every mobile
account and he has, you know,
his grandmother and his dog
opening an account, you know,
just because he wants to get to that
target will be going to pay him to opening
a mobile account.
But less than 25% are active and active
is generally defined as one transaction
in 30 days. That's the GSM made, you know,
definition of a mobile
account being active.
So we have yet to create the ecosystem
to have the customer can leave money in
their mobile account so that this becomes
a source of revenue for the brothers
bagging players. Because until
you get to a stage where I can,
so I was giving a mangrove getting great
tangent. I was giving a speech about,
you know,
what I call digital Pakistan and I said
three things need to happen and if we do
that, you know, will
get exponential growth.
The source was the one minute account
and that's actually taken place.
The second was the six orange purchase.
I should be able to buy six oranges
with digital cash as opposed to cash.
So if I'm in going to inbox then
you have a lot of hawkers you know,
people with just small is if
I'm being a one done a butch,
is it a paying him cash?
I should be able to pay with
digital cash and that acceptance,
a dig and players that you know that
merchant acquisition as in taking places
the end and when it does Sunday you'd
see a very high level of activity in
mobile account. And the third thing was
the five click onboarding that you know,
if you're sitting in a religion you
wanted to become an ecommerce margin,
should be able to do in five clicks,
be able to set up the photograph of the
product, set up your payment mechanism,
set up your logistic mechanism and the
fifth grade you should become a motion.
Obviously that needs three g and four g
coverage, which is happening in Pakistan.
So those things, when you have
those kinds of things happening,
suddenly you see digital transactions
taking place. So that was the challenge.
And I think we are halfway there.
So we've got the mobile accounts open.
Now we have to make them active
startup investor.
What is your view on the current
technology and entrepreneurial scene in
Pakistan?
So Pakistan,
remember the country of 200
million people, you know,
that's a lot of European companies
combine and you won't get to 200 million
people. But a lot of, you know, the
Lens you see Pakistan from here is,
you know, there's blood in the street,
there's bomb blast, there's, you know,
or the prime minister they
remove for corruption.
So negative news galleries easily.
And I've been trying,
I've been here what two days and I'd
met was turning 12 people already loaded
them vcs just talking about what's
happening in Pakistan because there's a
counter narrative towards
run by CNN and Fox, you know,
a lot of positive things happening.
So what's happened in last six,
seven years in Pakistan is an
emerging middle class, for example,
that 30 million people in the emerging
middle cloud with purchasing power
because the inflation rate has been around
for four and a half percent salaries.
And growth will company growth rate has
been around eight to 10% so people has
been plummeting getting incremental income
and now you have 30 million people in
one country which have purchasing power.
Right now there are 45 million
smartphones in Pakistan,
which is expected to go up to 80 million
by 2020 so remember the smartphone is,
you know, calling in, you
guys know this better than me.
Calling is just the 1% of a feature of
the smartphone is the biggest thing I
mentioned.
I see this happen in our lifetime and
it's going to revolutionize many things.
If you have a smartphone I can do,
he helps with you.
I can do education with you,
I can do he and genuine with you.
I can do if an financial services within
a doc Watson of these initiatives where
you basically the world changes when you
have a smartphone by 2020 Pakistan is
going to get 90% GSMs coverage,
three g and four g all over Pakistan,
just Sunday ruler.
Pakistan gets collected
with urban Pakistan and with
purchasing power increasing,
you've got a whole bunch of people who
can now be no box both ways they can buy
things with the previous didn't have
access to or I have access to them.
I can run remote education program,
I can do,
he held consultations at clinics which
are better. Doctor is President Karachi,
but I'm in a remote distant
part of Pakistan and I can
do diagnostics and then I
can use the payments to pay
the fee immediately happening.
And again use my iPharmacy who sent
the medicines out to those people.
So Pakistan, I'm getting connected and
this is what I'm dong the vcs over here,
that he has a country which is staffed
for seed capital that two PE firms and
three vcs in Pakistan and the largest
angel investor in Pakistan, which is,
and I'm far from a high net
worth as far as Pakistan is,
which family is a concern?
We just sitting on half a billion of
cash liquidity, half a billion dollars.
Okay. And if I'm the largest investor is
a travesty because these guys, you know,
can invest a lot more.
But I viewed this major opportunity
because I think Pakistan is grossly
undervalued with all these
things I'm talking about.
This big consumer vive is going to take
place and the valuation that will appear
time go up,
the vcs and bugs outside Pakistan are
going to recognize Pakistan is a country
where they ought to come and invest once
they get over the Pakistan risk hurdle.
Okay. And then, you know
what valuations we have now,
we're going to exponentially increase
and people who invest now are going to be
able to write that benefit,
detecting the initial risk and people
will get rewarded for being in Pakistan at
the right time.
Steve Question,
a question is that whether the regulatory
environment in Pakistan poses a huge
challenge to,
to the startups and what can,
what is changing and uh,
what can the startups do
to not fall into the dye?
So, you know, there's good news and
bad news. The good news. For example,
if people are starting and
microfinance institution,
Pakistan's regulatory environment is
recognized by the economic intermittent
unit as number three in the world.
So that's very sorted out.
But if you're not in a microfinance world,
then it's a challenge because the laws
are geared for the old economy is they're
not geared for the new economy. So by
like if you look at neighboring India,
they have started India where they've
taken five or six different things and
said we've got to change these laws.
If you're going to make an entrepreneurial
culture happen in India, Pakistan,
recognize this, those things. For
example, if I want to register my company,
I ought to be able to do
it online and pain this,
then they should be a separate window.
So that window exists,
but it's not very effective.
Right now. If I'm investing,
I should be able to do a
down round with Pakistan.
Lord doesn't currently allowed.
I should be able to give employee options
that Pakistan Lord doesn't curl be
recognizes. So we've identified all
the issues working with the security,
the Gates Exchange Commission,
working with the tax regime.
Now to provide shelter for both invested
in investees because you don't want to
have a lot of,
you know,
off that fed and you want to make
that invested. Actually, you know,
some prediction for that money
that gets written off initially.
So we are getting there in our day yet.
Uh, but it's recognized by the government.
Now that Pakistan has a largest
youth cohort in the world,
75% of people that are under 35 50% of
people are under 25 as these young people
graduate,
there's no way our current economy
can absorb them to regular employment.
So they hire has to be entrepreneurship
in order to make that entrepreneurship
is, it can be a dividend or it can be a
bomb because if you don't have employment
for the youth coming out, then they'll
get into what I call reverse ATM.
So when he's at a traffic light, as they
can have your phone, can I be a wallet?
Can I have anything else that would be
full? There'll be withdrawing from you.
None voluntarily. Okay. Because
you've got to give them employment.
It has to be means for
them to sustain themselves.
So that's why the diamond
in the private sector.
And that's why I have so much passion
for depression because I think that's the
future because Pakistan is such a young
population and I've worked with young
people and they have far more brilliant
ideas I can even think of and the need
if you know, environment where people
can believe in them, mentor them,
help them grow and provide capital.
But I'm just one person.
So maybe we need to have a whole slew
of people and support system from the
government that makes this a much,
much bigger player on a grander scale.
And we're getting there,
but we're not there yet. So a followup
question on that note, uh, how,
what role are detective
incubators playing? And uh,
if you can name a few which
are playing actoral in,
so that 34 incubators,
accelerators and Pakistan and I would
say probably three years ago they were
five.
So there's a mushrooming and understanding
that incubators and accelerators can
play a role. Uh, there's plan x, you know,
plan nine Nestio my incubate or Dell XC.
You know,
universities have incubators
as well, but the view, right,
the good news and bad news. Again,
the good news is that you know,
entrepreneurs who want to go into an
accelerator incubator program now are able
to get mentorships. They will,
I will to get coworking space.
The bad news is there's only one
accelerator that actually pays you,
you know our values you and gives you
money and once you graduate they're not
enough. Seed funds are, you
know, available over there.
Vcs that when you're graduating and your
initial capital is burned up to give
you money.
So the risk we run sometimes is that
you're going to have default rates far
higher than the natural 95% default grid
because there's not enough capital once
you graduate.
And that's one of the things that I've
spending at least a bulk of my time on,
is getting people.
So the seed and vcs at this or when
people graduate have a great idea,
they don't die because of lack of capital.
They are to die because it's
an idea that can be scaled,
not because they didn't know capital and
great ideas. Just, you know, finish it off
for maybe one last question.
Mesmerized.
There you go.
How long do you think it would take
for beavers to change as far as like
actually using digital while I
didn't do digital John's actions, uh,
orange, uh, thing that
you were talking about.
What are the constraints of the six audit?
If you know the banking business,
then there's something called merchant
acquiring that if you use your credit
card or a debit card at a merchant is
the point of sale machine pos machine
where he was just stripes your card
and you know, the payment gets made.
It takes money from your credit card
and you know, visit to the supplier.
So the constraint Pakistan was the deck
costumers that Boston machine costs
about, you know, that's it. $30 $35.
And if I want to go to a real small shop,
here's the hook.
When tree is not equal to
the $30 risk I'm taking.
If I were to build 100,000 margins,
I need $30 million of capital to put
a hundred thousand machines in please.
But technology is a way of changing
things and now you have QR codes.
So look you are report now at
the merchant can be put in,
we are post machine is no longer required
and if the customer has a smart phone,
you just to text, you know, puts a skew
or a board and a payment can be made.
But the challenge is still remaining is
that why would typically the bid that
the bank makes money is that there's
something going to much in Discount Rate
Mdr.
So if you started up a merger,
the merger is going to be
you one and a half percent,
1% depending on where you are in the
word as fees for the facilitation that
you're doing for increasing the sales.
Because other than cash it wasn't going
to come in and use a credit card or a
debit card.
But I'm mom and pop store to the Hawker.
Not going to give you 1% he says the
Dag, you very much. I liked Gash first.
He would ask me not to take guys they
didn't want to charge me, you know,
for not the gas doesn't work for me.
So this business model needs to be worked
out that if you create these margin
that you make money from float as opposed
to transaction fee and the Pakistani
markers not there yet.
So while you are a board has
been established and people
like experimenting like
Fingernail, you know, but you are
bored or HBL or to the master God,
there's real inflection point is come
and they figured out the business model.
But I think we had Martin probably a
year to 18 months away before that gets
correct. I'm going to dig a
shortage is about, so let's see.
Great. All right. So, uh, we have
one final question and maybe a minute
and a half for that pretty broad one.
What can companies like Google
and other bay area companies do,
um, in the, uh, in your opinion,
in the, uh, emerging markets?
I think, you know, one of the things, you
know, we would, a large players can do,
where do you honestly,
broad response to believe in Pakistan,
believe in the talent that exist
and use some of the, you know,
CSR and non CSR money in supporting that
and some of that you already mean done.
Tall Dell Xc my accelerator
as a specialty for, we know,
data cloud funding from
Google for startups,
but they're got to a lot more of that,
take some investment dollars,
put it in the infrastructure in Pakistan
because this is, like I said, you know,
a touring a million people
country with a large youth cohort,
which will become Google
customers for life, you know, uh,
so there's lots of one investment
that needs to take place.
Then a lot more understanding the
precision of what the local dynamics are,
not just for Google, but for other people
in the bay area who want to access the,
you know,
country of 200 million people.
[inaudible].